este vídeo le explicará qué es la inmuno
oncología y cómo funciona
la inmuno oncología es el estudio y
desarrollo de ciertos tratamientos
llamados inmunoterapia para el cáncer
y estos tratamientos combaten el cáncer
al fortalecer su sistema inmune
normalmente los glóbulos blancos de su
sistema inmune ayudan a combatir
infecciones y enfermedades
reconocen sustancias en la superficie de
las células llamadas antígenos
y las células sanas tienen diferentes
antígenos que las células del cuerpo
dañadas o los invasores extraños
las células del sistema inmune
usualmente ignoran los antígenos de las
células sanas pero si responden a
antígenos en células dañadas e invasores
extraños
algunas células del sistema inmune
marcan estos antígenos para su
destrucción con una sustancia llamada
anticuerpo luego otras células inmunes
atacan las células que tienen estos
anticuerpos
dado que el cáncer está formado por
células dañadas es posible que tengan
antígenos que sean reconocidos y
atacados por las células inmunes
sin embargo algunas células cancerosas
tienen formas de evitar su destrucción
por parte del sistema inmune por ejemplo
las células cancerosas pueden reducir el
número de antígenos tumorales
lo que les permite esconderse de su
sistema inmune
una segunda forma en que las células
cancerosas evitan su destrucción es a
través de las proteínas de punto de
control tanto las células cancerosas
como las del sistema inmune pueden tener
estas proteínas cuando se adhieren a la
célula cancerosa las otras células del
sistema inmune no las atacan
y una tercera forma en que las células
cancerosas evitan su destrucción ocurre
cuando las mismas son atacadas por el
sistema inmune
durante el ataque las células cancerosas
liberan ciertas sustancias que llaman a
otros tipos de células inmunes lo cual
ralentiza o detiene la respuesta inmune
las inmunoterapia tienen varias formas
de ayudar a su sistema inmune a combatir
el cáncer
una forma es a través de anticuerpos
especiales producidos en laboratorios
algunos de estos anticuerpos se adhieren
a las células cancerosas
pueden matar la célula cancerosa
directamente
y otros marcan la célula cancerosa para
que las células del sistema inmune la
destruyan
otro grupo de anticuerpos bloquea las
proteínas de punto de control esto evita
que se adhieran entre sí
como resultado la célula inmune puede
atacar y matar a la célula cancerosa
y otros anticuerpos previenen el
crecimiento de células cancerosas
algunos de ellos bloquean las señales
que hacen que nuevos vasos sanguíneos
crezcan y alimenten el cáncer
en otro tipo de inmunoterapia algunas de
las células inmunes que mejor combaten
el cáncer se sustraen del cuerpo las
células se llevan a un laboratorio donde
se cultivan muchas más luego se las
devuelve al cuerpo para atacar el cáncer
para obtener más información sobre las
formas en que la inmuno oncología puede
ayudar a combatir el cáncer hablé con su
proveedor de atención médica